مشكله جديده يعاني منها المواطنون مع
اشتداد الحرب والحصار هنا على قطاع غزه
وايضا مع تساقط الامطار وتوقف كامل لعمل
البلديات هنا في شمال غزه نتيجه تدمير
الاحتلال لاليات البلديات وايضا تدمير
الابار طبعا للاسف الشديد يعني وقعت
الكارثه التي كنا نحذر منها وهو غرق مخيم
جباليه نتيجه طفح بركه ابو راشد التي
توقفت عن العمل لاشهر منذ بدايه الحرب على
غزه نتيجه انهيار منظومه الكهرباء بالكامل
وعدم قدرتنا على تشغيل المولدات لا يوجد
لدينا سولار ولم يدخل لدينا سولار منذ بدء
الحرب على غزه هناك يوجد كميه من السولار
محجوزه في جنوب قطاع غزه من ضم مع مؤسسه
اليونيسيف
طبعا نحن نوجه الان النداء الاخير لاغاثه
مخيم جباليا واغاثه نفوذ بلد ال جباله بعد
تدمير معظم الاليات وتدمير معظم مضخات
الصرف الصحي والابار لا نستطيع تقديم ال
خدمه الان نحن بحاجه الى انقاذ حياه ارواح
الناس التي دخلت الصرف دخل الصرف الصحي
الى بيوتهم والى تجمعات النزوح والى
المدارس والعيادات والتجمعات السكانيه
الموجوده في نفوذ بلديه جباله نقدم نداء
استغاثه عاجل الى المؤسسات الدوليه وال
سيف والصليب الاحمر الدولي وكل المؤسسات
الدوليه المانحه وهو مؤسسات حقوق الانسان
الى انقاذ الانسان ماتبقى من مكونات للشعب
الفلسطيني في مخيم
[موسيقى]
جبالي ايضا كما نشاهد هنا هذه المشكله
تلاحق النازحين في مراكز الاواء هنا في
مخيم جباليا تجمع كامل لمياه الامطار
ومياه الصرف الصحي وايضا النفايات هنا في
داخل احد مراكز الاواء والذي يضم الاف
النازحين هنا في هذه المنطقه رحلنا من حرب
اجينا في حرب حرب اكرمكم الله المجاري
المجاري خشت علينا في الصفوف جوا وتغرقنا
وتبهدل واح واحنا يعني اولادنا كل يوم
امراض كل يوم نزلات معويه احنا نفسنا
مرضانين يا عالم احنا بشر احنا بني ادمين
ومن حقنا ان احنا نعيش من حقنا ان احنا
نكون بني ادمين ونعيش زي باقي الناس ننا
هي حالتنا وهي وضعنا وهي الماساه اللي
احنا فيها احنا وضعنا سيء يا ناس اطفالنا
هذول اطفالنا بيلعبوا في المجال اكرمكم
الله اوبئه امراض اوساخ في الصفوف عننا
يعني احنا من حرب اجينا في حرب احنا بني
ادمين وبنحب السلام وبنحب نعيش احنا بنحب
يعني نعيش زي باقي البشر اذا خطر جديد
يهدد حياه الاهالي وايضا حياه النازحين
هنا في داخل مراكز الاواء نتيجه تجمع مياه
الامطار ومياه الصرف الصحي وتوقف كامل
لعمل البلديات نتيجه القصف المستمر لاليات
البلديات من قبل الاحتلال وايضا الاحتلال
مازال يمنع دخول السولار لتشغيل مضخات
المياه هنا في شمال القطاع انس الشريف
الجزيره شمال غزه